oh shout out to Maino too man okay see
this is why we go long yeah keep on
bringing stuff up what happened with
Maino Maino choked out uh a tick tocker
I just want to know I don't know oh it's
awesome yeah no it's really good it's
really good hold on one second
you gotta understand and I could you
know
you dude like I don't know why your
advisors didn't forewarn you this is why
you need old men for Council and young
men for war because I could have told
that young man who not to play with
so this is a dude that like will
antagonize people like on the street
doing like a little thing so here first
of all right let me let me put on your
chin so I can see how I feel I want to
see how I feel like
put his hand on his shoulder and gave
him a little rub like hey now you just
chatting you know what I'm saying he's
letting him know yeah and now it's time
for you to relax because now I got my
guard up yeah yeah the next thing you do
I'm gonna take it as a threat and you're
gonna get choked the [__] out and for
whatever reason
why was this his next thing to say this
is crazy
10 right
[Music]
why would you say that to anybody but
why would you say that to Maino these
young kids man you don't know none of
mano's History bro so this is a vertical
video that someone posts on their story
look
did not survive 10 years in prison
survived the means creatures of Brooklyn
in 19 in the 1900s to be playing with no
tick tocker YouTuber yeah and why is
your line how fast do you think I could
beat your ass that's a threat yeah yeah
but I think that either I've seen
another kid do this or he does this and
it's the same kind of line you won't get
killed how bad can I beat you up you say
it to me I'd be like nine don't do it to
nobody you know he could do that to a
random person in a group this is what I
like about what Mano did is it
he knows the guy is not going to try to
beat him up he understands The Jig the
jigs is a tick tock right but the point
of The Tick Tock is to kind of make the
person being interviewed look [__] so
he's like you're trying to make me look
[__] and you have it on video so I have
to demonstrate let me tell you in some
way I'm not pushing let me tell you
something about Maino and Maino is an
evolved person yeah he's evolved a lot
when I first moved up here in 2006 I
learned quite quickly how not [__] may
not like it's not it's it's not that you
shouldn't even be saying those words and
may know in the same sentence
and you know what Mano used to call it
and it's so funny because this is what
he administered here discipline okay
what's the story that's what Mano would
say man it was like I had to he if you'd
be like yo Mano [__] up no no no I
administered discipline I love it and
that's what he did just in other words
you can tell or no I mean
people know I mean they Google it like
it's not like a lot of this stuff is not
like hidden like you can Google
Maino slap such and such our Maino beat
up such and so like it's a million of
them like while Mark looks that up has
anybody tried to intimidate you guys I
mean Mark put Marine discipline
I got the Charlemagne Google extension
okay I just Google it how you said it no
this is uh yeah there's like Maino I
disciplined Trinidad James on DJ black
he's like another one youngberg he
missed being slapped by Maino Maino
recalls yeah he just like he slaps
everyone it's crazy
yeah I could have told this guy that
wasn't gonna end well for you you gotta
know who to play with but I think this
is the ending he wanted exactly I don't
believe that
I don't believe that yo I don't believe
that and if these are the end things
y'all want please remember y'all not
this is not MTV jackass those guys were
getting paid millions of dollars yeah
okay to put themselves In Harm's Way
yeah y'all doing this [__] for some
[__] likes yeah and retweets yeah nah
bro and you know what this also does
this shows May not accept the precedent
now
[Music]
that's right now now I gotta [__] one of
you tick-tockers and YouTube was up was
that considered self-defense though
absolutely self-defense it was a threat
I mean the guy goes what happens if I
beat your ass absolute threat this is a
different Trend that happened a few
years ago I just want to bring it up but
it accidentally played super loud this
is a guy this is hilarious so this is
similar I don't know if you've ever seen
this chart but this is a guy who would
go and antagonize people and try to
fight them in in this in the hood and
and this is what would happen
this one right here this is
fire
this
is the one bro that's hilarious man can
you pull up these guys oh my God
man that is funny as [__]
idiots top-notch idiots these kids are
[__] crazy they go up to people's
they try to start some [__] yeah and
then right before they about to get
[__] up then they tell them yes that's
why you gotta leave people to [__] alone
yeah people have pulled out guns
peanut dog
that's wild
they want to fight
what you talk about them bro
scrapbook
well I didn't know if getting into
fights was that easy I didn't know all
you had to do is go to someone and say
hey do you want to fight right now
but that's not what they're saying
though Mark the guys like I'll [__] you
up well you want to get beat up you know
what I'm saying like but that's
different I just didn't know is that
he's in a fight I had never really been
in a fight yeah he doesn't have to pick
the right people I guess yeah you got to
pick people that want to L.A half the
time yeah you'll find people but it's
just insane but I'm like yeah to this
end yeah people want to pick fights and
get reactions on people with reviews and
Views is the currency so if I can go up
to Maino and say some crazy [__] just to
get him choke me out we're talking about
him if I'm Maino I'm suing
straight up so for what emotional
distress
because what's going to happen is that
dude might try to jump out the window
and do something do a lawsuit on Maino
you think Manor is going to sue someone
man he needs to because that's the type
of error we live in somebody will do
some [__] like that to you get that
reaction out of here you get to the
point where you need us to sign up
whatever the [__] to do these videos I
thought you had to do that now like all
the everybody on this video can sue
those guys they can everybody on this
video if they didn't get permission to
put them out I think at the end they
tell them they're like oh you're on
camera you're on camera is it cool to
put you on camera yes I think they get a
very you do have to get some permission
some of these people seem like they
would not be cool with it yeah after the
prank is done
give me your bone wow
give me your phone blood okay all right
look
um that's the episode
as always
if you listen to this podcast should we
should we announce our upcoming podcast
oh yeah you guys should do something oh
yeah we gotta do the fresh release soon
right oh yeah yeah we'll wait for the
press release for that